so how do you go to the back how do you
think it is is it the conversation your
brain so excited
really yeah if you ever tried new space
food just about everything that's
different you see things that you know
what they are but you but you haven't
seen them from that perspective before
but while your space walking which was
your question what do you do if you have
to go to the bathroom you wear diapers
what do you think of that that's like
when we were babies adults are babies
now like if you're trying to fix
something did you ever like what Goldman
yeah what do you think we could do to
try to prevent that from happening
your hand to it what's your favorite
food on earth Pizza yeah that's the one
thing that we can't get in space when I
was flying but now for the first time
they can even eat pizza in space how
would you call an astronaut well you
have to apply to become a become a task
force in an and I had to go to astronaut
school and I applied and I got rejected
three times it took me ten years when I
grew up I actually want to be an
engineer and I heard that your once
don't like didn't do something
just keep your curiosity going about
things and and learn as much as you can
and it's gonna get harder and harder so
just keep at it
[Music]